so vivid in my head they she emitted
immediately went from bully strong like
I've run this courtyard to house like
what just happened you want to look her
up yeah I know just what the [ __ ] she's
done to her disaster of her life it was
Condoleezza Rice actually would be crazy
she's angry at you for punching her all
this time Syrian [ __ ] but I'm saying it
could happen okay I'm with let's go back
to the the difference between you punch
in Rhonda's that would be the last punch
whoever threw I got slip you on your
head on the concrete smash your head
open stomp you into a mud puddle people
call this on video all they would say is
Eric Griffin domestic abuser strong
woman I don't lie first wean that and
Rhonda's a professional mixed martial
arts champion she's a champion and one
of the greatest female champions of all
time I didn't like seeing her face look
like she shouldn't have thought that
woman I just I didn't like seeing it I
got whatever what I'm saying there was I
couldn't I didn't feel any of that I
didn't feel any of the oh it's the
competition and she changed no what I
saw is a bruised and battered woman
that's what I saw
well and a my problem okay so you must
be talking about the Holly Holm fight
because that's when the one she was
that's when she got head kicked and
she's bloody you know just 48 seconds of
knuckles in the face yeah that was a
quick fight she just got the [ __ ] beat
out of her in that fight but but there's
lessons in that see you can fight in MMA
and there's there's danger and there's
consequences but if you're in shape and
you're prepared correctly you can fight
but there's a lot of women that weren't
prepared correctly and Ronda [ __ ] them
up that's just how it goes that's let me
sometimes in a more so like sometimes
you the hammer sometimes you the nail
was also hot pumped her up you know it
was like it was a money marketing it was
great marketing to she only hears a lot
of me I mean I pumped her up me doing a
lot of the but it was based on
what she'd have been able to accomplish
it wasn't based on [ __ ] it was based
on her actual performance inside the
Octagon against people like cats and GaN
Oh against people like Sara McMann what
she had done was supremely impressive
but you but but we would love a champion
mm-hmm we love undefeated love being the
best ever right we get behind that right
and that's what was behind her going
into that fight right and it didn't look
like that well that what that shouldn't
have been behind her going into that
fight maybe the Holly Holm fight yeah
Holly Holm fought even the Holly Holm
fight she was under massive amounts of
distractions she was under she was they
were had they were gonna do roadhouse
remember they're gonna do a Roadhouse
movie yeah she's having meetings with
agents and and they just thought she
could [ __ ] up anybody on the plan that's
what I'm gonna say the problem is unless
it didn't work a hundred percent all in
with your training and your learning and
your development your making sure that
you've got the right training partners
and the right coaching and the right
staff and nutrition all these different
things if you don't if you have any any
part of that missing then the people
coming up who have all those cup bases
covered
they're gonna surpass you but see you're
talented too and that's what happened
with her you're knee-deep in the world
you know everything about it okay as a
layperson right just looking at them
standing next to each other I was like
oh she gonna get her ass beat so you
looking at Ronda standing next to Holly
Holm yeah I thought the rod was gonna
get her ass beat yes I when I saw it I
was like it's gonna work why did you
think that I don't know Roxanne I test
she just looked Holly girly physically
she was bigger she was done she was
physically bigger than this person
neither I've seen Sara McMann no Rhonda
stop Sara McMann in one round Sara
McMahon was an Olympic silver medalist
in wrestling and she's a tank I wasn't
into it like that maybe if I'd seen that
I would have been like well this is
gonna be a good fight but that was my
first time and I'm just looking at it I
was like this doesn't look like this is
gonna be a good fight that's just you
know it's just I just didn't I just
didn't think it was gonna be a good
fight and then I went you didn't you
hear just you hear you guys talking you
hear like the guys gonna get all that
Holly hope said she's a boxer in this
and then I'm like oh wow
this isn't gonna go well and then sure
enough it didn't go well so then that
made me have like is the respect level
for
female you know fighting if I'm just
coming in like at that time you you know
it was like Ronda Rousey's everywhere
she's in movie she's in like you know
and then you're like oh wow this the
greatest fighter ever right here this is
the this she's the the attraction of a
lifetime and then you go okay alright
I'm gonna check it out let me check out
wow that girl look big I don't think
this is gonna then she gets demolished
and you're like why is this a sport I
think that was a big blow for female
fighting what are you talking about
those like one of the best things to
ever happen to feeling okay well we're
different in that way I think she should
have won would have been the best thing
no no no it's good to know that anyone
can lose even the greats
even the Great's they get to boxing too
much is what it is boxing has got to be
yeah be undefeated you know boxing we
love undefeated one blemish on your
record in a head it does something you
know doesn't work like that right
because an MMA there's so many different
ways to win the only one who's really
undefeated at the top of the food chain
is well two guys khabib nurmagomedov
who's the lightweight champion he's
undefeated period mauled everybody
except al Iaquinta went the distance
with him and you know but still beat his
ass still beat him but john jones is
really undefeated john jones has won
lost his career but it's a
disqualification he's he's a guy that's
been disqualified because he was well
got caught with some [ __ ] in his system
that he shouldn't had in the system and
how did he get it in his system we don't
know it was only in there for a very
short amount of time there's a lot of
speculation we don't until that gets
ironed out by the way